jetzt perfekt und herzlich willkommen
bei einem neuen video ja ich hoffe
natürlich geht es gut herzlich
willkommen zum dandy upload hier auf
einem kanal für jeden tag 19 uhr neues
video beschreibt solchen die ohren und
aber den kanal blog aktivieren chapman
surface alex w
also ich bin zurzeit wirklich so aktiv
wie nie und sich sogar und deswegen
mache auf direkt bereit hat mit dem
nächsten video weil ich habe mir nämlich
was ausgedacht und zwar so früher als
kind wenn ich in der eisdiele war
ich habe wirklich super super gerne
milch getrunken also einfach so in
vanille mexiko milchshake der milchshake
manchmal hab ich auch keine mehrheit
bekommen weil der halt zwei euro fünfzig
gekostet hat und zwei kleine kugeln 120
oder so auf jeden fall hatte ich
deswegen bock auf so ein kleines format
wovon man auf jeden fall auf mehreren
partnern kann ihr wisst ja ich mache
sehr gerne zur zeit was mit essen und
ich war einkaufen habe alles mögliche
gekauft hier ganz wichtig bio caps und
papier strohhalme ich finde es wirklich
kasse sowieso strohhalme klar für ein
milchshake ist damit es aussieht kann
man die man benutzen aber das ist ja
fast in jedem restaurant als strohhalm
und wer hat werden warum brauchen wir
ein strohhalm alle deswegen die leute
verzichte ich auch schon über das ist
super wichtig weil strohhalme helfen sie
auch immer gescheiter heißt also das ist
wirklich mit das nötigste was auf diesem
planeten geht zurück zum thema milch
shakes genau und zwar habe ich gedacht
hey du machst einfach mal irgendwelche
menschen kreation und guckt was am ende
herauskommt mit irgendwelchen zutaten
die du so feiert muss mal kurz den
kühlschrank ausstellt wichtig ist dabei
auch wie immer dass ihr vielleicht auch
so ein paar ideen in die kommentare
schreibt wie der nächste mac aussehen
soll
heute habe ich mir einen kitkat
milchshake überlegt also deswegen
ich habe mich sogar im internet ein
kleines rezept dazu gefunden habe das
ein bisschen angepasst so wie es meiner
meinung nach gut schmecken könnte
und heute machen wir halt ein kit kat
menschik ja ich finde wirklich gespannt
da würde ich sagen wir aber gar nicht
lange fragen direkt an ich mache das
alles aus dem kopf her ist und wir
schauen einfach mal wie das endresultat
und ist hier ist mein mixa den ich
letztes mal gekauft habt hier ist der
mix und hier ist dieser behälter davon
was wir als erstes tun müssen ist
natürlich die kinder auch machen ja
sogar fünf stück angehen ich fragen ja
alex diese ängste mit kitkat an also
frauen hast du pic hat gewählt ist ohne
frage aber ich war früher gehabt wir
haben eine marke gab zu hause und
deswegen kerkhoff gewählt und die
anderen die sich fragen wo ich schon
wieder juli ist hinter der kamera ist
eine berechtigte frage
der ist nämlich schon wieder im urlaub
der war es zwei tage hier und ich heute
morgen wieder urlaub gefahren oder
festival oder so tritt auf malle auch
sein ins profil wenn ich euch immer ein
und schreibt ihm eines dm oder so warum
er denn in meinem urlaub was ich jetzt
erstmal mache ganz einfach hier das kit
kat trennen und reinigen
also insgesamt hatte ich da ich glaube
kann man hier das sollte jetzt locker
schon reichen also das waren jetzt zwei
fliegen
man muss natürlich sagen ich habe ein
bisschen zu viele kind getauft aber es
gab stimmen wie kann man
aufgefahren das ist halt die base ist ja
ganz klar so jetzt suche ich einfach mal
nach gefühl ein bisschen milch ein
ungefähr so 150 bis 200 milliliter würde
ich mal sagen das sollte eigentlich erst
mal reichen denn das wichtigste fehlt
eigentlich das war einmal so war jetzt
kommen da meine eigenen vanille schulen
in meinen milchwerk rein also früher
halt noch klein war habe ich mich immer
richtig gefreut und es war habe ich mir
natürlich nicht nehmen lassen mal wieder
einzukaufen als von meiner lieblings
marke nein ich habe extra für heute die
kleine portion gewählt also ja 2,5 liter
habe auf jeden fall schon mal bestens
eis gegessen wir können hier jetzt auf
jeden fall nach ungefähr drei bis 400
gramm eis zu weil es das überhaupt passt
also da muss man auch nicht was rein
noch
[Musik]
ganz bisher noch so sack das sollte
jetzt eigentlich auch schon reichen
und das ganze jetzt noch ein bisschen
abzuholen dann kommt noch ein ganz
kleiner schuss schokoladensauce hinzu
einfach hier oben rein da da war das
sportliche portion ich gebe mal kurz die
hände waschen kommt machen wir das ding
in folge ein bisschen münchner oben
drüber
ja weil hier so zahlreich dann schrauben
wir das mal zu ich will zwar kurz auf
die kleine käme weil wir müssen eben in
die küche mir ist aufgefallen ich habe
ja gar keine steckdose ich trottel ich
bin echt mal gespannt ob das was wird
mit also ab in die küche
herzlich willkommen ich bin jetzt
wirklich mal gespannt das ist das erste
mal dass ich mir selber einen milchshake
zu bereiche und auch selber diese mixa
für den milchshake benutze
deswegen schauen wir mal ob es klappen
wird ich bin da guter dinge
3 2 1
also ich glaub ich kann's stücke sind
noch nicht klein genug deswegen kommt
einmal noch
[Musik]
also sieht eigentlich schon mal nicht
schlecht aus machen das nur vorsichtig
auf also ich muss sagen ich bin
zufrieden wir haben jetzt bestimmt also
dass schon das werden meine eisdiele
früher eine große portion gewesen da ich
mich sehr darüber gefreut muss man ganz
klar sagen würde ich sagen schnell
wieder ins wohnzimmer wir machen weiter
herzlich willkommen zurück das ist der
fertige milch steckt sich die kurzen
becher also so eine größe hat bei uns
früher eine also zwei bis 250 kostet
genau weiß ich es auch nicht mehr
jetzt also perfekt ja das ist doch gut
also ich habe ich meine eigene beratung
also fahren lernen
ich habe es zwar noch kein geschmacks
gemacht aber ich bin wirklich schon sehr
zufrieden
es riecht gut und es sieht gut aus ich
als profi koch hat mir dann gedacht also
ein bisschen sahne noch drauf deswegen
einer ist immer schwer
[Musik]
oh ja wohl unsere unterlässt stellen
natürlich noch ein paar schuhe sträuße
jetzt ein papierstau am rhein
zack und ich würde sagen alter leute ich
bin so zufrieden
also irgendwie gedacht irgendwas
passiert mir wahrscheinlich wieder weil
ich volltrottel sowas eigentlich nicht
selber kann ist einfach so metzger wir
machen den kurzen jüdischer
[Musik]
[Applaus]
okay ich bin wirklich nervös kommen zum
finale ob es mir schmecken wird oder
nicht weil ich weiß wenn es nur
schmecken wird werde ich mir das öfter
machen und so vision ist es ja auch
nicht
also sieht auf jeden fall aus wie vom
profi gemacht so als hätte ich's einfach
eine eisdiele bestellt reitverein ich
bin ehrlich ich habe mir gewünscht dass
ist noch besser schmeckt das problem ist
also alles schmeckt auf jeden fall voll
gut keine frage ist geil das problem ist
nur hätte ich mir auch denken können
aber durch dieses kit kat sondern auch
so ganz kleines stückchen drin und das
feiere ich persönlich nicht schmeckt auf
jeden fall brutal nach kind card und es
schmeckt mir werden die stücke heraus
wer ist auf jeden fall eine 10 von 10
jetzt würde ich sagen nicht gemeint acht
punkte also das geht besser trotzdem gut
gemacht ich würde sagen er schreibt mir
mal rezepte für eure verrücktesten oder
lieblingsmenschen kreation oder
irgendwas wo ihr im kopf sagt ja das
könnte gleich schmecken schreibt es mir
die kommentare like kommentare von
anderen leuten wohl sagt er hat eine
coole idee dann sehe ich das immer das
ist super wichtig ansonsten abonniert
den kanal jeden tag um 19 uhr oder
manchmal am wochenende freitags und
samstags gibt es das video erst um 20
uhr
ja warum weiß ich nicht ist nun einmal
so das war's abonnieren glaube hat die
wir noch finster hat sich alex w
da könnt ihr mir auch jederzeit gerne
video idee hinzu kommen lassen
wir sehen uns morgen und wenn es nur
drei